[Music]
made of glass
[Music]
yes
corsets painful heels brutal prosthetics
oh my to bring the disney fantasy world
to life these actors had to endure not
so comfortable costumes makeup and
prosthetics all in the name of art we've
got 15 of the most painful costumes
disney actors have worn in films coming
your way number one her name is cruella
why would we expect her outfits to be
comfortable i couldn't walk anywhere or
sit in a car or do anything with all of
that she was the peak of fashion in this
film but she did pay a price the
legendary garbage truck dress train ran
40 feet long and was too heavy for emma
stone to wear so the train was only
added when she was ready to go riding
into the night on the back of a garbage
truck then there was the mask she wore
making her first cruel appearance this
mask on my face it was crystals glued on
and feathers glued on so it took a very
long time to do yes glued directly onto
her face that process was not fun but
the look so worth it we are hashtag
blessed to wear the brilliant designs of
academy award-winning designer jenny
bevin and her incredible team number two
her wardrobe was as uptight as she was
obviously because i didn't next i
couldn't get into anything because i was
wearing a corset yeah those corsets
don't leave much room to breathe much
less eat but what made it worse was the
combination of costumes and accessories
she was managing i'm in a wig that's
literally this high and heels are that
high i've got a champagne glass in 103
dalmatians in the other this seems like
a disaster waiting to happen that's not
going to be easy you guys thompson
pulled it off for the cameras but it
wasn't easy i said i'm gonna fall over
and i fell over number three we're
heading to the transformation station
aka the hair and makeup chair where
angelina jolie had multiple people
working to bring maleficent to life this
three hour application and then one hour
removal process following shooting were
the hardest part of filming the
maleficent films for jolie everything
from the sharp cheekbones to heavy
makeup to the headgear she had to wear
to keep her horns in place added to the
torture of the transformation the
custom-made leather horns that added a
full foot to her height weren't just
painful it made doing her job difficult
as well since the horns were often
ramming into parts of the set and her
surroundings for the first while
eventually she got used to it but it
never really got easier to manage oh and
don't even get us started on her 5-inch
heels
number 4 sleeping beauty wasn't so comfy
when she was awake elle fanning's
wedding dress in maleficent was stunning
but it didn't make filming very easy the
actress was pretty restricted explaining
it was tons of fabric i couldn't walk or
go anywhere without someone holding it
up for me oh and to make sure nothing
happened to the dress between takes
fannin got sent into a horse box all by
her lonesome number five those glass
slippers aren't all they're cracked up
to be it doesn't fit a foot because it's
made of swarovski crystal i know it's
too much the shoes we see on lily
james's feet throughout cinderella are
actually cg since the beautiful heels
were anything but practical as for her
tightly fitted blue dress well you know
there were corsets involved it's drawn
in with yes
very tight just getting into that outfit
took 45 minutes that included about 12
layers of costume as uncomfortable as it
was james made the situation a bit worse
for herself because of her on-set drink
of choice i drank quite a lot of coke
and i was burping a lot in the course
take note all future disney princesses
corsets and coke are not a good
combination number six prince charming
was feeling real constrained in those
pants of his it's disney and i'm in skin
tight um trousers yes he was richard
madden knew that period costumes for
women were usually uncomfortable but
after his experience filming cinderella
let me tell you something
that like it's nothing compared to what
the boys have to go through part of his
costume involved tightly fitting jock
straps and the process of finding the
right one was rough chris was just
basically a corset for men you was like
tears wailing
i'm gonna be sick not only was he
uncomfortable physically madden wasn't
so crazy about how exposed he was it was
very constraining in ways i'd not
imagined number seven a whole new
wardrobe and this one was heavy mina
massoud dazzles in aladdin wearing
updated and gorgeous looking costumes
his royal seaming digs in particular
unfortunately wearing the beautiful
fabric wasn't so easy because of just
how heavy the material was considering
they were filming in an already warm
climate you can bet masood was sweating
buckets underneath layers of ostrich
feathers capes and gold number eight
being a princess can be great except for
when it comes to the outfits aladdin saw
naomi scott wearing beautiful dresses
like the royal pink dress but she wasn't
quite as happy wearing it as she seems
on screen the bodice itself was
extremely tight but what made it
difficult for her to work were actually
the gold coins adorning the costume
director guy richie didn't want the
dress to rattle too much as the noise
would ruin takes but with that many
coins and needing to you know move
around freely well it was a bit of a
nightmare to pull off number nine are
corsets comfortable in wonderland i wore
a corset for the red dress and the blue
dress at the very beginning of the film
and they were very painful okay so turns
out they are just as uncomfortable no
matter where you wear them poor mia
vashikovska was struggling to film at
times feeling extremely restricted and
distracted because of the pain like the
pro she is though this actress made it
work and it set her up well for enduring
corsets and future projects too number
10 we have got to talk about this giant
head of hers because they were still
laughing in my big head what exactly was
it that brought this larger-than-life
head to the screen there was cgi used to
amplify the size but before any of that
took place helena bonham carter sat
through a long makeup process involving
extensive prosthetic and wig application
the large wig added a whopping three
pounds to her head are we sure she
wasn't saying off with her head about
herself number 11. his costumes may have
contributed to his going mad johnny depp
had the works when he betrayed the mad
hatter and alice in wonderland the actor
wore some wild style wonky teeth
flamboyant makeup and some of the
creepiest contact lenses you've ever
seen one of them painted just ever so
slightly off those wild eyes were the
most painful part of his transformation
making it difficult to work but it
didn't take away from his character at
all if anything it helped him feel even
more mad if that didn't do it then the
long airbrush makeup process could have
been what put him over the edge number
12. this beauty of a dress was a real
beast to wear and not in a good way this
iconic yellow stunner of a dress was
glammed up with a whopping
2160 crystals on top of the multiple
layers of heavy fabrics one hardship
watson didn't have to endure though was
wearing a corset the actress outright
refused to wear one not wanting to be
more uncomfortable than she really had
to be while working number 13 he didn't
quite look like a beast behind the
scenes but he did look very
uncomfortable and it wasn't just dan
stevens who struggled with his outfit
figuring out how to dance with dan on
stilts
pretty difficult stevens was wearing a
40 pound mocap suit throughout filming
and to make matters worse he didn't even
have a stable base this guy was casually
walking around in stilts or at least
trying to or walked down the stairs that
was that was quite that was heels are
rough but 10 inch stilts that's a whole
other level number 14. beauty is pain
cruella deville herself didn't have the
best time in her costumes but we can't
ignore how epic they were costumes are
the character among her many elaborate
outfits were very high heels she wears
you know four-inch spike heels and
restrictive clothing while the actress
wasn't so comfortable performing these
costumes also seemed to put off her
canine co-stars they don't want to have
anything to do with me to be fair
knowing her history we can't really
blame them number 15 honestly what can't
mulan do we are beyond impressed by her
on-screen combat skills but who knew the
armor sash and panels she had on during
this epic battle were composed of 40
feet of material while the whole outfit
looks fitted and like it flows well it
really restricted her ability to move
especially when it came time for those
acrobatic stunts and i think it really
helped we knew beauty was pain but these
costumes yeah we take a hard pass on
most of them which costumes do you think
would have been toughest to work in